ÿ
>> AFTER DECADES OF BOOMING
GROWTH, THE COMMERCIAL REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRY HAS RUN INTO A ;
a
BRICK WALL.
BUILDING VALUES ARE PLUMMETING,;
a
FURTHER
VANESSA YURKEVICH IS HERE WITH
MORE.
>> Reporter: THERE'S STATUESQUE,
VAST AND STAGGERING, AND THEY'RE
EMPTY.
SKYSCRAPERS AND OFFICE BUILDING;
a
ONCE STACKED HIGH WITH
BUSINESSES ARE EXPERIENCING HIG;
a
NEARLY 19%.
5.5% HIGHER THAN BEFORE THE ;
a
PANDEMIC.
>> I THINK IT'S A VERY UNIQUE
MOMENT, NOTHING LIKE ANY ;
a
DISRUPTIVE MARKETPLACE THAT I'VE
EXPERIENCED OVER THE PAST 40
YEARS.
>> Reporter: THE PANDEMIC ;
a
EMPTIED OFFICES AROUND THE ;
COUNTRY
TODAY THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE ;
a
O
AREAS, FORCING COMPANIES TO
RETHINK PHYSICAL OFFICE SPACE.
HALF OF THE BIGGEST GLOBAL
COMPANIES SAY THEY'LL NEED LESS;
a
REAL ESTATE IN THE NEXT THREE ;
YEARS.
LEAVING LANDLORDS WITH LOANS TO
>> NO TENANT, YOU'RE NOT MAKING;
a
MONEY.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> THERE'S NO RECOUPING LOST ;
a
INCOME FOR DOWN TIME.
>> Reporter: STEVEN DORELL RUNS;
a
THE LEASING AT SL GREEN, NEW ;
RENT, THE COLLAPSING DEMAND FOR
OFFICE SPACE MEANS THEIR TENANT
VACANCY RATE SHOT UP FROM 3% ;
a
.
HERE.
>> SL GREEN IS WORKING WITH BAC;
a
LANDLORDS AT 332 BUILDINGS ;
ACROSS NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY,
WITH FILM AND TV COMPANIES.
THIS EPISODE OF "LAW & ORDER" ;
a
.
E
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE STARTING ;
a
TO LOOK WHOLISTICALLY AT HOW ;
>> Reporter: THIS YEAR SL GREEN
SAYS IT WILL EARN $3 MILLION
FROM FILM AND TV SHOOTS. ;
a
.
>> Reporter: EMPTY OFFICE ;
a
THIS PROJECT IN WASHINGTON, ;
.
BUT THAT'S NOT AN EASY, QUICK
FIX PROCESS.
LESS THAN 1% OF APARTMENTS
NATIONWIDE ARE CONVERTED FROM ;
a
COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES.
AND ACROSS THE RIVER IN
ARLINGTON, VIRGINIA, THE CITY I;
a
TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF ITS EMPTY
OFFICE SPACE PROBLEM.
22%.
>> I'M SITTING RIGHT TODAY IN ;
a
.
>> Reporter: THANKS TO NEW CITY
ZONING LAWS, THAT'S NOW
POSSIBLE.
ALONG WITH SEVEN NEW TYPES OF ;
a
ANIMAL BOARDING, HYDROPONIC ;
.
JERSEY.
THIS 22,000 SQUARE FOOT PICKLE ;
a
STRIP MALL.
REGIONAL MALL VACANCY IS AT A ;
a
WERE THERE A LOT OF OPTIONS LIKE
THIS ON THE MARKET?
>> YEAH.
I THINK WE HAD MORE OPPORTUNITY
THAN WE THOUGHT THERE WOULD BE
>> Reporter: PICKLE BALL IS THE;
a
FASTEST GROWING SPORT IN ;
AMERICA.
SO DOES THAT MEAN THAT THE SPORT
NEEDS TO FIND PLACES TO PLAY ;
a
QUICKLY
>> THE GREATEST THREAT TO THE ;
a
.
>> AND OBVIOUSLY PICKLE BALL IS;
a
A GREAT WAY TO DRAW PEOPLE INTO;
COMMERCIAL SPACES.
THIS IS ALSO HAPPENING IN ;
a
.
OPEN IN AN OLD SAKS FIFTH
AVENUE.
WE SPOKE TO LANDLORDS WHAT THEY
FEEL LIKE WILL BRING BUSINESSES;
a
AND PEOPLE BACK INTO THE OFFICE;
.
SO, THINGS LIKE OUTDOOR SPACE, ;
a
BETTER FOOD OPTIONS, BETTER ;
THINGS TO DO ON YOUR FREE ;
a
MOMENTS AT WORK.
IT'S A TOUGH TIME FOR COMMERCIA;
a
REAL ESTATE.
ALL THE BANKS ARE SAYING ;
a
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THESE ARE THE LENDERS, RIGHT?
>> WHAT ARE THEY SAYING?;
a
>> SO YOU HAVE SOMEONE LIKE BAN;
OF AMERICA SAYING THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE WORST SITUATION;
a
SINCE THE FINANCIAL CRISIS.;
THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE
MANAGEABLE.
YOU HAVE OTHER BANKS SAYING THA;
a
WAIT AND SEE.
RECESSION COULD OBVIOUSLY MAKE
THIS WORSE.
NO ONE IS REALLY ON THE SAME
PAGE RIGHT NOW ABOUT WHAT THIS
IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
BUT AT LEAST WHAT WE'RE SEEING ;
a
IN MAJOR CITIES, FOR EXAMPLE, ;
.
YOU HAVE THE OFFICES LEAVING.
YOU HAVE THE RETAIL LEAVING AND
FEWER PEOPLE IN THOSE CITIES